Yeah.
Uh,
in video three,
we discussed the origins of the Socratic
method and how Socrates was using this
intense form of dialogue to try and
awakeness to a more meaningful and
reflective way of life.
In this video,
I want to build on the Socratic way of
thought and how these ideas parallel and
eventually merge with the type of
meaning we observed in ancient Israel.
If you want to be caught up,
you can check out those videos first.
Or if you don't like being told how to
live your life, just carry on from here.
A steady was given in which children
were presented with two rows of candy and
asked to choose which one they wanted.
We can clearly see it doesn't matter
which one they pick because both rose
contain five but almost every child would
reliably pick the bottom row because
it looked larger.
A child's perspective is only able to
focus in on a small amount of information,
so if something looks larger in
their mind, it must contain more.
It is an illusion we can easily see
through as adults because we possess a
perspective that the child is not before
you take this information and begin
rubbing it into the face
of your six year old.
I want to show you one more example.
The nine dots puzzle is well known to
many psychologists and the challenges to
drop for continuous straight lines which
go through the middle of all nine dots
without taking the pencil off the paper.
It seems pretty straightforward.
Hmm.
The problem is the way our
mind frames this puzzle.
We assume there was an invisible boundary
which forms at the edge of the box
that we cannot go beyond,
but it is not until we step outside of
our initial perception that we are able
to solve it. When shown the answer,
many will say this is cheating,
but nowhere in the rules does
it say stay inside the box.
That is a restriction we impose on
ourselves with his method of a Linkous.
Socrates was trying to shock people out
of the nine dots of their day to day
concerns.
He felt the narrow perspective of his
fellow citizens with steering them towards
eighth thoughtless and selfish life.
Now we know Socrates was executed partly
for his disruptive form of philosophy,
but mostly for pulling a
Bart Simpson and his trial.
Socrates never wrote anything down,
so we don't have any firsthand
accounts of his life.
Everything we know about him
comes from secondhand accounts.
The most notable of these were
by Socrates student Plato.
Plato was traumatized by the execution
of his mentor and he spends the rest of
his life trying to understand how
people could be so foolish and so self
destructive that they would kill
someone as wise as Socrates.
Plato begins writing his dialogues,
which were essentially little plays,
most of which center around Socrates
and his method of a Linkous.
He did not write these dialogues simply
for us read or encounter the viewpoint
of Socrates.
Instead,
Plato is trying to get us to
see something about ourselves.
What he is trying to get us to realize
ties in with the two experiments we did
at the beginning of this video.
Let's say we take a child who is
looking at a problem they want to solve.
This is the child's perspective of the
problem and the parents is they're trying
to help them.
Of course,
the perspective of the adult encompasses
so much more because they have more
life experience as the adult helps them.
The child will begin to imitate the
words and actions of the adults.
One of the reasons our species has
thrived is that we are very powerful
imitators and we have an intense
trust in those we imitate.
This was shown very strongly
in an experiment in which
a chimp and a child are
each shown an opaque box.
The adults pulls and presses a series of
levers and a candy comes out the chimp
watches and does everything the
human does and gets the candy.
Then they repeat the experiment with
the child who does the same thing.
They repeat the steps and get the candy.
Then the experiment is repeated with a
box that is now completely transparent,
so it is obvious that the last action is
the only thing that releases the candy
and then the box is turned over to the
chimp and the chimp does only the last
action and gets the candy.
Then they give it to the child and the
child repeats all the steps they can
clearly see are useless,
not looking so good for team human,
but there's something very
important happening here.
The child may see that
all the steps are useless,
but they repeat them anyway because
a child trust that the adult has a
perspective which is greater than theirs
and has some purpose beyond what they
can understand as the child imitates,
they are gaining the ability to
internalize the adult's perspective.
It is very hard for us to recognize our
own biases because we live within our
own perspective and it can be
very difficult to see through it.
When the child begins to take on
the perspective of the adults,
they can now take on goals that are
much more longterm and far reaching.
Eventually the child doesn't
need the adult around anymore.
They have gained the ability to
take on a perspective of their own.
The child moves to adulthood
by internalizing the
mind of an adult's butts.
As we showed in the nine dot problem.
I have my own biases that
I can become trapped in.
If I approached this problem as a connect
the daughter solving a connect the dot
problem.
I will keep making the same mistakes,
but it is possible that there is a
perspective that is greater than mine,
which I could internalize to become wiser.
This is our idea of a sage.
They represent a perspective that can
see above and beyond what we can like the
child is to the adults.
The adults is to the sage.
I can become wiser by internalizing
someone wiser than me.
That is why Plato wants to give us
Socrates and acted as a living person.
He believes that if we
can internalize Socrates,
we can reorganize our psyche to live
a more harmonious and meaningful life.
Plato wants to understand why humanity
is so prone to foolish and self
destructive behavior and he creates a
psychological theory to account for this.
He says that each of us has
three centers of cognition.
There is the monster which
represents the appetites,
the lion which represents honor and
the man which represents reason.
He believed these three centers of our
cognition and we're constantly getting
into conflict and anyone who has ever
tried to set longterm goals knows this to
be true.
The recidivism and failure rate for any
new diet is around 95% the reasoning
part of our brain knows
that we should eat better,
that it would make us
healthier and happier,
but our appetite overpowers
our longterm goals.
Another part of our psyche is responsible
for looking at all the possible
consequences our actions
might have in the future,
but we all know this voice is much,
much quieter.
The final piece of this
model is that the lion,
it is not quite our emotions or feelings,
but more like our spirit.
The lion represents our socialization.
It represents that process
of internalization and
we talked about earlier.
It is how we adopt the perspective
of other people onto ourselves.
Plato says that we can teach the men
who can then train the lion and together
the lion and the man
can control the monster.
It is the internalization
of Socrates or the sage,
which empowers us to deal with our
own self destructive tendencies.
This is a radical transformation and
reorganization of the psyche and Plato
argues that we have a
fundamental desire to do this.
We want this conflict to be resolved.
We want to experience inner peace and we
are craving a culture within ourselves.
Plato takes these ideas and links them
together. In his most famous story,
the allegory of the cave, there's a group
of people who are trapped in a cave,
chained facing a wall with a fire burning
behind them and puppeteers casting
shadows against the wall of the cave. The
people chained cannot turn their heads.
They could only watch the shadows and
they believe these are what is real.
One person gets free from his
chains and turns around. At first,
he is blinded by the light of the fire
until his eyes adjust and he can now look
at his surroundings. The fire reveals
a pathway going up and out of the cave.
As he starts to walk up the path with
the light of the real world blinds him
even more until again,
his eyes adjust and now he can see
the real world outside of the cave.
He wants to see the source of
all the light in the world.
So we observed the sun and then he goes
back down into the cave to tell the rest
of the people that what they think
is real is an illusion. Of course,
his eyes are now adjusted to the light,
not the dark,
and he stumbles about and looks
like nothing but a madman to Plato.
It is the philosopher that makes this a
scent and this journey into the light is
Plato's theory of enlightenment.
So here's our psyche.
It is disorganized, are different,
natures are at war with each other.
We learn to internalize
Socrates or the sage,
which puts us a little more
in order as we do this.
Our inner conflict is reduced.
We can see into the world more clearly.
We are more connected to reality
and how things really are.
As we see the world more clearly,
what is real,
what is truthful now
becomes more salient to us.
It starts to have more of
an impact on our psyche.
We are less trapped within our bias
perspectives. We gain more inner peace,
which in turn allows us to see
even more deeply into reality.
This allows us to internalize the sage
even deeper and this process continues to
feed back onto itself.
This is how we walk out of the cave.
This is Plato's is sent
into the light to Plato.
This is what makes life meaningful and
in was this meaning that Socrates was
willing to die for.
We can see that this is different from
the form of meaning we saw in ancient
Israel both focused on moving from the
mundane world of self deception and self
destruction into the real
world or the world of paradise.
In future videos,
we're going to look at how these
ideas emerge and grow together.
Then we're going to look
at how they were all lost,
and that is the meaning crisis
we detailed in episode one.
Yeah.